welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question it's a podcast that
gives you
too much information about how the real
snyder cut
is the one that knicks an artery and
causes death
i'm eric boss with me is zach huddleston
how you doing buddy
i'm doing great eric it's good to be
back um blue dungeon to jason
yes and uh uh i won't try to read too
hard what
secrets you have written on your cards
in the background our editor hopefully
in post will put in other offensive
things that we'll blame for
most of these are offensive to the
editors all right well we are in the
middle of dc week here at new rock stars
uh we did breakdowns of man of steel
batman v superman we got coverage of all
the big updates from dc's fandom coming
we know we just got some big news about
the snyder cut robert pattinson batman
we're so excited
the breakdowns of all that will be
coming out over the next couple days on
the channel keep an eye out for it
today zach and i are going to explore
one of the more contentious
points of zack snyder's vision for this
world the insanely high body count
superman in these movies literally sinks
into an ocean of skulls
batman gets his organs ripped out by
homelanders superman now sure both of
these you could say our dreams but
are they dreams are they
we never really get confirmation of what
he was going through in the nightmare
sequence whether that's the future or
the dream
i'm afraid i'm scared we should be i
think that was
what was intended by mr snyder he wanted
to scare us pantsless
he's just standing there menacingly
or for some of us shirtless but you're
not getting a look at my chest hair mr
snyder
now look i don't want us to look like
we're two
little snowflakes and get triggered like
i don't get too mad really
when it comes to snyder's choice to have
his batman and superman kill i get it
it's like
it's his vision it's his variation the
dc theme as long as it's like mostly
justified by the situation which they
usually are like it was totally
justified for superman to kill zod
in that scene i get it but it's still
super fun to talk about across these dc
eu films between these two characters
who's
more responsible for more deaths so zack
the big question's coming your way
this week who has killed more people
batman
or superman and zack snyder's dc eu okay
and yes we are limiting this just to the
dc eu
man of steel batman vs superman and
justice league
so don't come at me with batman returns
he shoved a bomb in a
giant clown's pants and threw him off a
bridge okay we know
there have been some maybe kills that
both these characters pass
and obviously in the comics there's so
many issues and so many variations so
we're limiting our scope to the more
recent dc eu
and i'm also going to talk about not
only the kills that happen in those
movies
but like put them into three different
categories a direct
kill right pink mist
i shoot you i punch your head off
whatever an
indirect kill or maybe the actions of
our hero led to somebody dying even if
not directly
oh okay and then a death by inaction
they could have done something
and they chose not to thus letting
somebody die
okay and maybe we'll wait these things
differently because they are they're
morally kind of different
deaths yeah well i mean once you've
taken those lives it still weighs on the
soul the same way having done all three
i can tell you from personal experience
gabe drew phillip zach you're next
what i haven't seen marina in a week or
two
um okay let's start with our main bat
boy
batfleck ben affleck in the batman
appearances
uh starting with batman v superman um
our first time seeing him
we see him with this whole like branding
the criminals
thing right when he catches the guys he
gives them a brand which i gotta say
strategically because the dceu version
of the bat symbol
is so just like amorphously rectangular
i don't know how effective those brands
are somebody could be like
oh uh you're into rectangles or
rhomboids
oh you're walking to a cattle poker at
one point
i got one too there's a vaccine scarves
that are
kind of worse than some of those brands
but regardless we find out that when
some of these branded criminals
go to jail they get killed for having
those brains right they're targeted
and it's a mixture of we find out lex
luthor
is paying criminals shout out yeah long
beach legend ct fletcher pays uh plays
the um
uh criminal and also maybe just kind of
like the way that certain criminals like
child molesters are treated in actual
prison right or or
or snitches it's talked about that um 18
criminals have been branded
and we see at least two of them die so
we could maybe assume
18 ish criminals have died indirectly
because of that potentially yeah
and his and his hot blade there hot
knife and all these dudes
okay so there's that but that's indirect
he didn't mean for those people to die
he just wanted them to be permanently
scarred and to suffer greatly
also indirect or possibly in action
so we know that this universe there is a
dead
robin at least one probably maybe a
jason todd and a dick grayson
but we see the graffitied up uh costume
and so we don't know how that happened
we can assume the joker killed him or
them in that batman either
wasn't able to stop them through
inaction maybe the inaction of not
killing joker
ironically or indirectly by
letting this guy or guys uh fight crime
with them or children
or children teenagers
can you imagine how insane it would be
to have like a 13 year old sidekick i
mean the movie kick ass did but so
two more deaths on his ledger possibly
in action or indirectly
now let's get to some direct kills uh as
you mentioned that nightmare sequence
desert camo batman he's he's got no more
cape he's just got like a cowboy slicker
on
and he is machine gun and fools machine
gunning vaguely nazi
uh superman acolytes so there are pair
of demons
in the background there but most of the
soldier guys that batman
is shooting don't appear to be
parademons they are masked
but they appear to be humans but it's
also implied that parademons might be
like transformed
you know higher intelligent creatures it
might be people who have been like
transformed into parademons there's
definitely some grounds there that like
killing a parademon is also taking a
life yes because you know what we never
find out
can those pair of demons be rehabbed
right after they've painted no one ever
asked that
no nobody's asking these kind of hard
questions here after those pair of
demons have paid
their debt to paris society why can't
they re
para join us again we estimate just
based on gunshots and bullets that seem
to connect
he kills about 12 people 12 humans in a
sequence
but of course we find out it's a dream
or a
nightmare if you will right so these
don't count
unless this movie is it kind of plays
with this idea of like
or is that a vision of the future and i
don't know about you eric i don't
normally um dream about murdering
a dozen soldiers do you no i dream about
the first
half of senior year still trying to
finish my extended essay and my other id
essays that i had to write and for some
reason friends from college are there
and then um the hosts of the talk for
the job i used to work on
are my teachers yeah i i still up until
about two years ago i still
had the nightmare of it's the last day
of the semester and i've never been to a
single class and i haven't studied and
now i have to take the final yeah
but now i think that shifted to it's
five minutes before i wrote theory
episode and i don't know
how uh spider-man 3 is going to unfold
it's the same thing school never ends
okay so i'm not going to count the
nightmare kills and this isn't the last
time we're gonna talk about their
nightmare sequence but because it's
technically a dream we don't get
confirmation
i'm not gonna count those on batman's
ledger who i am gonna count
are those uh bad guys in the port chase
sequence
we literally get to see a couple of
those dudes get their heads caved in
he machine guns a bunch of guys he lands
the batmobile on top of some guys he
crashes through some dudes
all kinds of mayhem and carnage here it
is
direct and it is purposeful he is not uh
setting his phasers to stun
yeah he's straight up shooting dudes i
mean they're shooting at him
i'm not we're not saying it's not
justified but you know other batman have
tried to find ways to not kill people
this one's just like nope they're going
down judge jury executioner just like
superman
was worried about right again we don't
know how many of these bad guys were
like dennis hayes bird's character and
he
they just got out of the pen they're
trying to go straight but you know what
being a sugar cook is hard okay
sometimes your old your old crime
buddies wave a big payday in front of
you and you do one last job and maybe
that last job was down in gotham for
whichever point that was
yeah and you get shot to death by a
billionaire
okay so how many people died of that
okay so we counted it up it seemed like
about 13 people right you can't always
tell them about
all these cars that are getting flipped
but seems like a good baker's dozen
worth of bad guys and then last but not
least in this movie for batman
the most graphic uh and visceral
right that warehouse fight where he's
going to save
martha kent right we see him slam dudes
heads into the ground
like leave blood smears on the walls
when he like slaps guys
i mean my favorite when he does that
with the uh he hooks the box
and throws the big crate at the guy i
mean calling mailman because he delivers
know what i'm talking about
[Laughter]
i mean that's a postal service that'll
never get defunded i love
it shouldn't be political that's what's
crazy about it
absolutely it's the mailman moving on
to justice league okay the the only
other time we've seen batman
in the dc eu and not including suicide
squad but i don't think he actually we
saw him kill anybody in suicide squad
in fact he kind of almost got beat up by
non-powered uh will smith right
uh for the sake of not embarrassing in
front of his kids his daughter
saved that billionaire's life in fact he
saved another life right because he
saves uh harley quinn's life
yeah he saves harley quinn joker you
think he killed but you can't kill that
joker he's gonna get going back
[Music]
so in justice league that opening
sequence
right where he uses the criminal to kind
of lure in a parademon
and then kind of attacks the parademon
to the wall i'm not
it's an indirect kill i'm not gonna
count it on batman's ledger
because technically the parademon like
self-destructs
right he kind of just emulates while
being stuck
yeah there because uh batman helps him
along in that process
but really he was trying to get
information from that parrot demon you
could argue he wanted that parademon to
stay alive longer to try to find out
what
the whole mother box conspiracy was
about and presumably this is one of his
first interactions with the parademon he
doesn't know that
you know they're like a shark out of
water and they'll die instantly the
second they can't fly or something right
um so you could forgive him for that but
speaking of
pair of demons right we have that tunnel
sequence the water tunnel under gotham
right he he seems to kill directly six
parademons in that sequence okay now
that's a good question again
are pair of demons are they humans now
in in our series
well they're not humans well or i guess
like does it count as a death
are they intelligent life we don't we
don't know like have
when you are converted to a parent demon
is your life over
right is this like a walking dead
question where like when you see your
ex-wife now as a zombie a is she
are you still legally required to pay
alimony to her
right or are you still kind of in
california yes
yes in california yeah and so like we
don't know also
because you know uh steppenwolf is is
not just bound to the realms of earth or
whatever
these parademons could be aliens that
were converted or they're like you know
you could argue they're orcs that are
just bred on the planet apocalypse
either way
you know in lord of the rings orcs are
intelligent life they're not that smart
but it's a life that you take if
gimli and legolas count them i think we
should count these parent demons
okay i'm sold you know what we need to
expand our views
count more things as living creatures or
or sentient creatures right
i'm all for it so he killed six sentient
creatures there
these are fairy devils with wives and
kids and you know they're parts of book
clubs
um okay and then uh in that final big
battle
where everything's red and they're in
the weird russian town right
uh he seems to have killed about 25-ish
direct paradise in that sequence right
he steals one pair of demons gun and
kills a couple
he lures a bunch into a building when
he's in the batmobile and the building
kind of blows up on him right
there's some creative ways uh i would
say it's probably not
as deadly as wonder woman i feel like
was the mvp of that battle sure yeah
wonder woman
cyborg aquaman they kill way more that's
one thing i liked about this final one
thing i liked about this final battle
is like batman really struggles with
these things it's not like
chatari where they're just mowing them
down with a single body slam
he like once they jump on his car he's
like oh [ __ ]
like he he doesn't do that thing where
he just like flips a james bond ejector
seat and they fly off
he deals with he never gets them off he
needs diana to come in there and fight
him
yeah i kind of like that he struggled
yes and even with his fancy toys
this is crazy like spidermobile and all
that right yes
he's not as nimble and agile as all
these other kind of powered characters
right yeah he needs the rest of the team
yeah which is good i mean it kind of
makes sense he's the elder statesman
there he's the grizzled
event right right so that puts the total
number of kills for batfleck right about
86 ish but if we're saying direct
right and creatures he chose to end
we'll say 53 is his kill count wow
okay all right sounds good let's let's
move on to that other uh
beautiful slab of uh muscle and jaw
henry cavill superman
coming in hot in man of steel
okay and i mean all meanings of hot okay
and all meanings of coming hey you
show that peter parker clip baby
so starting with right like kind of one
of his seminal moments
speaking of coming okay um uh
you know a formative moment if you will
for him was when pau kent right jonathan
kent
they're caught in that freeway twister
out of nowhere
right and superman he's like oh get
get mom to safety right superman's just
chilling under the overpass
well paul can't waves goodbye before he
gets swept up
in a twister stop about
you know super speed ability to fly
there's a 150 yards between them right
he could have covered that distance no
problem
yeah that was a layup but he chose not
to i think out of fear
of revealing himself yeah paul kent said
let me die rather than maybe one of
these kids accidentally seeing you move
fast
also low-key the whole reason uh
kevin costner into the twister was to
save a dog
i'm sorry my dude i love animals i've
got
i've got a tiny pug sleeping in the room
next to me right now
bro your life is worth more than that
dog right you better cover that pug's
ears you don't want to hear him saying
like uh oh
zach does not value me that much i'm
less than a parademon you can kiss my
furry little butt
there are people i would consider taking
a bullet for i can't think of a single
animal i would take a bullet for or take
a twister for in this case
i mean hey it's a trope right like
everyone always goes back for the dog
dogs seeing a dog get hurt in a movie
is more painful i think than seeing a
person get hurt in a movie it's just
it's a weird thing
people love dogs oh of course right and
then the whole saves the cat
moment right is that yeah oh yeah that's
something which it should be
save the dog no one gives a [ __ ] maybe
that's why it's because people are like
why would you say the cat
cats are great but like cats don't care
about you once you save them
dog you don't you could just like look
at a dog and smile and they'll be
forever loyal to you
dogs are so much better also we both
know cats are too smart
no cat would ever get caught in a car
[Applause]
um dogs are dumb i i love dogs i'm a dog
person but they're done
okay so there's that one and i will say
that that is a
a death of inaction right and it was a
conscious choice it's an almost direct
inaction right he chose to do nothing
when he definitely could have and that
was an important part
of kind of the genesis of this version
of superman jump forward in time a
little bit
to that battle of smallville kind of the
gas station right we get our first kind
of direct interaction with superman and
in the zod squad and it seemed like
about four civilians or in that gas
station are in cars
there's like two bicycles right next to
the gas station which makes you think
that maybe there was two little kids
in there you know sody pop and some
charleston shoes
and then their eyeballs popped from the
extreme heat
yeah and then they they melt into a pile
of goo
and of course there's a military
presence there and the the zod squad are
yes knocking down helicopters and and
all this kind of stuff
one of the guys that rips off a pilot's
head mid flight
and then you see his blood spray
everywhere we talked about that in the
breakdown that one was tough to watch
brutes but of course that's not superman
directly doing that though you could
argue that superman
hadn't discovered that scout ship design
squad wouldn't have come
yeah if superman wasn't there in
smallville you know they would those
other kryptonians would not be there
right so it is an
indirect thing and if you say that like
indirectly well we can't give him
all those bodies but he probably
deserves some percentage of them so
let's
let's just throw out the number nine
right that some that's maybe
40 of all the deaths that happen in that
sequence and yeah
i mean he didn't kill any of those
people directly but like his presence
caused all of them to die
and he did he did work really hard to
save people like he saved us
a ton of lives so like maybe we get some
extra credit there he definitely gets
some extra credit there but he also
could have moved the battle somewhere
else he didn't have to fight in his
buddy pete ross's ihop
he could have done it in the waffle
house which is not going to have as many
people
and the people who are in the waffle
house expendable that's absolutely right
it's out on the edge of town by the
adult bookstore you know
in that shady liquor store nobody should
be there
so it's strip row yeah so then um
the next two we're going to talk about
are going to be i think even more
controversial
than that that kryptonian genesis
chamber
all right uh so the ship that
superman kind of goes captain marvel on
and destroys
we know from that opening sequence with
russell
crowe jarrell on krypton right that like
within that genesis chamber there are
these like kind of
uh brussels sprout esque pods or stalks
with these
these like pods on them right that that
birth kryptonians
and so we know that those things were
also in that ship
that superman destroys and you can kind
of do the math
there seem to be in that opening
sequence there seem to be about 26
stalks ish or how many you can see and
each of them have about
30 let's say like cryogenic chambers egg
chambers whatever
on them so if you do that math that's
about
780 not quite born yet
kryptonians that superman consciously
chooses to kill he even says
i'm not gonna let you kryptonians
survive
yeah you know it's it's almost like the
ripley and aliens moment like
she's popping all those eggs and that's
what superman's doing there
he's just like using his heat vision the
way she used to flamethrower we
i think we can get those numbers because
like when russell crowe dives in
to the genesis chamber there's like a
whole bunch of there's a bunch of those
pools
because that's like their home world we
can imagine that one of those pools was
on that ship but i think it's safe to
assume that what we can see in one of
those is probably
it's a standard size they're an
efficient culture they probably make you
know roughly the same amount
because there's probably some algorithm
that says you need this many
in order to repopulate a world
absolutely right whatever the kryptonian
gross
is right a dozen dozen kryptonian gross
now here's where another debatable thing
is right these things are
are not fertilized because superman has
the codex
right that's what they they need him to
be able to
oh yeah it's in his cells yeah yeah
right so
when when does life begin eric oh
well definitely not before uh conception
i mean the people arguing that say that
you're baby killing every time you
menstruate
like that would be insane or like i
guess there are some people who say that
masturbation is a sin
uh and guess who's not a member of that
club
[Laughter]
[Music]
and so i i think like though he kind of
killed 780
potential kryptonians i don't think you
can really say
they were a death right it's almost like
yeah maybe you could say
he neutered the potential
right maybe he snipped the nut sacks or
the ovaries
of uh 780 worth of kryptonians
right yeah did superman know that his
father had encoded the the kodak into
his cells that's something that zod and
his scientists figured out but like
as far as superman was concerned he knew
there was a genesis chamber on there
he didn't know that whether those pods
were fertilized or not
to be willing to kill 780 babies is
almost as bad as actually doing it zach
that's true and we
we have no idea how much he knew about
what was on that ship
right like we have to assume he was down
to stop the kryptonian threat to earth
but he didn't necessarily know the
ramifications of like what's in every
closet on that ship
right zod should have told him in that
moment there's a daycare center
there are children on the aircraft he's
just like i don't care krypton had its
chance
oh we have a school here there should
have been some like uh some baby
carriages
maybe like a cradle or two just sitting
around just something
some fisher-price toys yeah yeah
see see some doodles on the walls
that are you know toddler height but
they're like kryptonian doodles so
they're like badass
covered in crazy armor for no reason
okay so though you could say you know
780
we're not going to count it right
there's there's too many ifs okay
there i'm not going to count it on
superman's kill count at least his
direct kill count right
but now okay the big shebang okay the
battle of metropolis
one of the most controversial things
about the dc eu
double or triple 911 right there in the
middle of metropolis
at least yeah oh hardcore right okay
so we're not gonna put the bodies on
superman of like when the genesis engine
kind of like blows up stuff initially
obviously that was totally oh yeah
the world engine is flattening yeah
superman did everything he could to stop
that
yeah right right so we're not gonna put
all of that on him
certainly now again just like in the
battle small bill he probably deserves a
little bit of that credit because they
wouldn't be doing that
if superman wasn't on earth right
curiosity kills the everyone
that's right that's why i have chosen to
never be curious i'll live forever
uh but now especially you could put
a lot more onto superman for when he
chooses
to fight zod in the middle of metropolis
right and they're smashing through
buildings they're collapsing skyscrapers
right
and we can see because we see lois lane
right right over there there's people
kind of
still in the wreckage we can assume
maybe some of metropolis was able to
evacuate but like um
a major we know that in the dc eu
metropolis has 11 million citizens
to get 11 million people out of a major
metropolitan area impossible in the
middle of the day with no warning
yes these office buildings are filled
with people right even if some of them
were able to get out you know some
people got out of the towers
911 but lots of people did not so we
have to assume
in fact a consulting firm that
specializes in like damage assessment
watch this movie and guessed there was
about 379
000 people killed overall yeah
yeah that's probably right i mean there
were dozens of skyscrapers that
collapsed onto
thousands of people running around in
the streets that makes sense
unfortunately yeah
i mean pedestrians people in cars trying
to get out
right who knows like you know a couple
buses here or there maybe even like a
collapsed subway system
it's insane and it's not to mention not
to go too dark right
a lot of the people that died from 911
died from diseases
asbestos i don't i don't know what the
ocean codes are
for metropolis right but you have to
imagine there's going to be
so much ptsd we know at least one guy
was paralyzed
and that came into play later right yeah
that's right that was a big deal and
that led to so many more deaths
and didn't zack snyder say there was
like about 5 000 people died in
metropolis but that is
crazy that's like when the mcu was like
oh like a couple hundred people died in
the battle in new york it's like
no directors you have a choice to put
what number there
just round up just be realistic with how
many people died
no one's gonna fault you for the number
adding an extra zero to it you know yes
if if you choose to collapse buildings
then it's on you
okay they could just be punching each
other in the parking lot you know and
whacking each other with stop signs or
something like that
but you wanted them to smash through
buildings okay and yeah and here's where
it's heaviest on superman's head he
chose to fight that dude in the middle
of metropolis
right superman too going back to
christopher reeves the first time we
kind of saw
zod on screen right yeah he drew the zod
squad
out to like uh middle of nowhere to
fight them so there's not as many
players that was a choice
right superman could have done the same
thing hell both these dudes can fly
they could just go up like a quarter
mile under the sky and punch each other
silly but they chose to slam each other
through buildings at any point superman
could have like
used his intellect and like hey zod
let's make a deal and we'll make a deal
20 miles away or whatever it'd be like a
defensive lineman
saying like you'll be able to push me
back into the goal line and then i'll
tackle you
it's like the whole point is to stop the
forward momentum
to do further damage that's that you're
trying to protect that's the
one task at hand is to protect lives and
you're thinking that the best way to do
it is to like
slowly jump in front of that lex corp
semi truck that he
like you know just grab them and fly
them into space
do everything you can to keep that fight
on the moon absolutely and
you know i think the defenders of
superman in this situation would say
that he was trying to save all of earth
because zod was basically gonna wipe out
everybody if he got his way if he wasn't
defeated
but i think that's part of the the
conflict
of a hero right like batman
could kill joker the first time he comes
across him
kill you and thus save the lives of
everybody that joker will ever kill
but because he's conflicted he has to
take the high rodeos to be a better
person right
he said he locks up joker knowing that
he'll get out in a year and
probably kill a couple more innocent
people but here superman does not take
that attack
and instead he says actually some people
are going to die in metropolis but it's
for the greater good but he's willing to
accept casualties
i don't know we could go back and forth
well it just doesn't really seem to
bother him that much
i think that's a big thing he's more
upset by killing zod than
like thousands of people dying and of
course right that battle ends with a
very direct kill
the old next napa rooney he gets a point
for that one for sure oh that's a that's
a big old fat point
okay now fly forward batman for superman
there's one very direct kill early in
that movie the kind of kenyan warlord
that's taken lewis lane hostage right uh
superman
smashes him through a wall right that
dude's definitely dead poor guy
yeah that's the way he lived he found
out he was kind of a stooge or a patsy
right being set up and then in the
nightmare sequence we talked about
before
we know batman had a lot of kills there
but of course so did superman we see him
directly like
you know laser vision half a dozen dudes
in half
and in theory all those goons that are
there they have his emblem on their
shoulder right they're there on his
behalf
under his orders right so you could
estimate maybe there's about 30 people
that either he directly or his goons
kill in that sequence but again
it was all a dream so we won't count it
but again man still shady still
questionable we're still
visually seeing superman kill people on
a screen
and the shock that that entails okay now
flashing forward to that capitol
building sequence
the guy armed in the rubble of the
battle of metropolis
it's got a explosive wheelchair given to
him by lex luthor
we did a little estimating math here but
let's say about 220
people right we see all the people in
that kind of meeting chamber
you have to assume there's offices all
around there i mean it's a gigantic
explosion right and you had press
lawmakers and like
protesters all kinds of people in there
so 220 seems like a pretty good
number there for how many people die of
course not directly caused by superman
but that dude was pissed at superman
that meeting's taking place because of
superman
it's crowded because of superman i mean
there's a lot of senate hearings in
which it's like
you know cricket and especially right if
superman didn't show up
that dude wouldn't have set off the bomb
right because the bomb was intended
to either kill superman or more likely
to kind of like
set him up as a bad guy yeah yeah lex
wanted to
set up superman as like a further enemy
he was
working both sides to try to get
superman and
batman to hate each other more and more
and more and more yes
it's complicated it's a very complicated
scheme too big for little minds
but you know so let's say those are
indirect kills
and then finally end of the movie the
doomsday fight
he does successfully kill doomsday
so that's a direction yeah he gets him
kill uh dies in the
process so you know could have been a
little more efficient there but
hey yeah got the job done yeah and then
finally in justice league superman's not
there for most of the movie of course
uh he gets violent when he gets revived
and he certainly wrecks a cop car
too right and kind of beats up on the
justice league but doesn't kill anybody
and he also misses most of that
final sequence when all those parademons
are getting killed so it doesn't really
that's right doesn't even really kill
any of the parademons he's he's pretty
inactive in the movie so no kills for
him
almost useless they didn't separate
those three mother boxes
so great nerfed
he did the equivalent of like hey
superman can you open this jar of
pickles please
great thanks the world's saved if only
opening jars of pickles could save the
world guys i would have saved so many
worlds
okay a very few tangible skills in life
but i can open a dryer pickles
final tally here and again i talked
about different categories of kills
we mentioned some that we're not really
going to count so this is this is the
final
zack approved boom boom kill counts here
for superman and batman and dceu
direct kills of batman
53 especially for counting parademons
direct kills of superman assuming we're
not counting weird fetus pods
or people in buildings that get
collapsed on top of them or whatever
he's only got three superman only has
three kills really direct
confirmed kills the kenyan warlord zod
and doomsday
and really you can make an argument all
three of those are pretty bad dudes
probably deserve to die
yeah so i think you know in in our
standings
uh batman way deadlier directly
superman way deadlier indirectly he's
over 95
000. we're gonna attribute all of them
yeah yeah yeah that's an important
distinction
i guess we can say that superman might
be deadlier but batman is more of a
murderer
the difference between uh you know jason
voorhees and the hulk
the hulk has yes a lot of people have
died because of the hulk but well i
guess you could argue jason boyce
doesn't even know he's
killing that many people there's also
estimates that jason 4 he just killed
thousands and thousands so maybe it's a
bad example
that guy's done a lot he's going to
flash back to
the video you made with tommy where he
used famous horror movie villains
kill count i think jason voorhees was
the top level uh well thank you for
breaking that all down
and uh let us know what kills you think
should be counted and shouldn't be
counted because they're
you know there's a lot of skulls a lot
of skulls get cracked to this movie
but we want to thank some people who
helped us make this episode first off
thanks to our sponsor
full sail university so full sail
university zack and i know that because
it's located just outside orlando
florida we had a lot of friends who went
to full sail it's this great institution
it offers associates bachelors
and master's degrees designed for the
world of entertainment media arts
technology
uh their online and on-campus programs
are accelerated
so you can earn your degree in half the
time we know a couple people who are now
like working as editors as filmmakers
in all kinds of creative industries here
in la who they all went to full sail
it's just kind of interesting to be like
what wow wow what are they doing there
that's working so great
so full sail degrees are immersive but
hands-on so you can learn your craft
using the same tools and technologies
found in the industry
you're studying full-sail grads are able
to come back and audit classes
throughout their careers
and receive lifetime career development
support that's
awesome very few other institutions
which would let you do that that's
awesome full sail grants have gone on to
do big things from mixing hit records
working on major hollywood films like we
were talking about to
winning oscars winning grammys uh me
when i checked it out i was most
intrigued by their online bachelor's and
digital cinematography degree with its
courses in directing and film criticism
lots of cool stuff they're teaching
there
to learn more about full sales programs
as well as potential scholarship
opportunities visit
fullsail.edu big question
we also want to thank our friends at
expressvpn for sponsoring this episode
so when you use the bathroom you always
close the door behind you right
zach at least 50 of the time well you
should do it 100 of the time because
using the internet
without expressvpn it's like going to
the bathroom and not closing the door
behind you
and 50 of the time bad things can come
in and do bad
bad thanks to you your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit folks
and what's worse is they can sell this
information to ad companies
tech giants dark forces out there in the
world who will use your data to target
you in dark scary ways
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device
and the internet so that your online
activity cannot be seen by anyone
i use expressvpn on all my devices it
works on everything phones
laptops even routers so everyone who
shares their wifi can still be protected
even if they don't have
expressvpn isn't that great we're just
trying to do as much for as many people
as we can
and the best part is using expressvpn is
easy as closing the bathroom
door which it should be easier but zach
i guess i guess it's kind of hard
but next rsvp in makes it really easy
all you got to do is yeah fire up the
app click one button you're protected
extra cpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by cnet
wired the verge and countless others so
if you're like me and believe your
online activity is your business
which it is for most of us nowadays
secure yourself
by visiting expressvpn.com bigq
today use my exclusive link that's
e-x-p-r-e-s
big q and you can get an extra three
months for free that's expressvpn.comq
okay we have time for one more uh little
box of scraps question
and this question this week is do you
have a
terrible drinking story
oh yeah yeah yeah of course i think
anybody that's ever had a drink has a
terrible drinking story
yeah it comes with the territory well
i'll i'll lead
here and this is i i don't have a great
tolerance for anything
i enjoy sip of alcohol maybe other legal
substances
but i've never been able to handle like
very much of those things right and
that's okay because i know my limits and
i usually am good with them but
occasionally
i make a mistake and one time that comes
to mind it's about 2009-ish i had not
been in la that long
and i went with two friends to a party
at the
usc law school we had a friend who was
going to usc law school so we went down
there
fun kind of party it was kind of dying
down we got there kind of late but they
had
a big bowl of sangria eric you know this
about me
i love fruit
not the alcoholic component there's
fruit in this beverage
yes so they need a big like a giant
punch bowl worth of
sangria and it had like diced up apples
and like
pineapple and grapes and all this kind
of stuff maybe some melon in there you
know whatever it was a fancy kind of
sangria
and i love whole fruit you know chunks
of fruit whatever
and so i was like oh i i didn't know
anybody at this party it was kind of low
energy anyway so i kind of posted up by
the sangria bowl
and i'm just kind of popping out little
chunks of fruit snacking on those you
know i'd already had a drink or two so i
didn't need to drink that much more
well lesson out there for people that
are not aware of the powers of sangria
the alcohol collects
in the fruit oh it soaks in you can't
deceit
yes the cherries and it's kind of masked
by the flavor of the apple or the grape
or whatever
so i was eating basically like shots of
booze
while i was snacking oh yeah it's like
jello shots that you're doing
yes and it just kind of but you're
unaware because you're used to like oh i
could drink
two or three drinks great but you don't
realize how much you're consuming when
you're just snacking on fruit so anyways
flash forward
an hour or so goes by we're gonna head
home and so my friend is driving
luckily i'm not driving in this story
and i'm in the backseat
he and his girlfriend are in the front
two seats and we're on the 110 freeway
going through downtown la
when it hits okay and i get
i get the spins i'm nauseous i already
kind of get carsick even when i'm strong
cold sober
so things go bad we're going down the
freeway like late at night so there's no
traffic probably doing 60. i just
real quick have to roll the window down
and hurl on the freeway
but luckily i feel a little bit better
15 minutes later we get home
as i get out of the car i realize that
the entire back half of the car there's
just a giant
bright red streak down the side of the
car
because the first you drop them off you
know all the vomit kind of slaps back in
the car
and it was all bright red because all
this sangria so that's my uh
drinking story it looks like painted
it's like this person
sideswiped a bike messenger yeah all the
people that were driving next to us on
the freeway were like
what happened to this car plus my friend
he got out the hose hosed it down
and i was fine the next day so that
that's amazing
um i've had a lot of terrible drinking
stories
because uh you know we went to a state
school it's kind of a party school
it was one of the schools was florida
ever number one on the number one party
school usually penn state was number one
but it usually made the top ten i feel
like yeah yeah
so we would do a lot of drinking and
then coming out of college i still kind
of had that college mindset of like
i love getting drunk getting hammered
with my friends
wild night yeah but i was never that so
i would brag to my older brother i'm
like you should just see me in college
like i was i would get drunk all the
time i'd get oh i got
i would tell him these like glory
stories that were like he's probably
just rolling his eyes like all right
because he was like in a frat like my
brother is uh
he's like in the navy like he's he
definitely like puts him down
i went on a trip to japan uh he was
living in japan at the time so i visited
him
it was awesome it was it was such a
great trip he showed me tokyo
um and tokyo has a part of tokyo called
the roppongi
district and it's known as like it's
where you go
drinking it's like uh it's very
westernized there it's where a lot of
like the businessmen
and and western tourists will go because
there's just like a ton of
bars like a ton of whiskey bars because
whiskey's a huge deal in japan
it's it like rivals scotland in terms of
like where you can get like
the the finest whiskeys but they're all
about
it's not like roppongi is where you're
gonna find nice whiskey it's very just
fine
you know they just have crappy whiskey
bars it's like bourbon street or
something right
yeah man yeah yeah yeah so he takes me
this far and he's like all right
if you're such a big drinker uh and he
takes his place and all it is is a shot
bar
but we're there for probably an hour but
it felt like three hours because every
time someone rings a gong
it means that uh whoever did that bought
a shot for everyone in the bar it's like
super cheap shots and you have to do a
shot or it's bad luck
so like really the truth is of like all
my stories from college i was drinking
the lightest beer in the world
i wasn't drinking hard liquor if i did
it was super like
watered down and i had done one of them
and then i like fell asleep and took a
nap and that was enough
here i was like oh my god i'm gonna die
um i've never blacked out so hard at
some point
when i was given a shot i would just
hand it to this these dudes next to me
and like later my brother was like yeah
you were talking to these like
businessmen in their 40s for like uh
you know 20 minutes and you're singing
songs with them
and i was like i don't remember any of
this and i don't remember
anything after that part we went to
three more bars that night
three more bars and i don't remember any
of them he's like yeah at one point we
got this like street food and then he
started eating me and my buddy's street
food
and i'm like what and he's like yeah you
kept ordering more drinks and we're like
i guess you can handle it
and i was sick the whole rest of the
trip
like i we we went to other there's so
many cool places to get drinks in tokyo
there's this uh
area called the golden gai district
where there are these tiny little
closet-sized bars and you just hop you
go from bar to bar to party pay a small
little cover
and then you just drink one of the two
beers that they have there um and i
i couldn't have more than one drink the
whole time and he's like are you okay
you're not talking to anyone i'm like
i'm still sick i never want to tweak
again
i'm too much a baby but like yeah
there we went to this robot bar in tokyo
which you've been to tokyo this is the
thing you do it's just crazy like
it's a robot restaurant they have like
these robot fights and they have these
girls who have keg backpacks and they
come around and they fill up your beer
and she have to be she's like you want
beer and i'm like no stay away from me
um
yeah careful beware the roppongi whiskey
bars because they'll get you there's a
uh
a wrestling tag team called roppongi
vice because they used to wrestle in
japan
i might have wrestled one of them that
night i wouldn't know you might be
married to one of them we don't know
well that is our show thank you so much
for joining us uh this week for the big
question thank you zach for breaking
down those numbers for batman and
superman from the dcu fascinating
insights there and and you can send us
your questions on discord
using uh our discord server it's a great
community but it's exclusive to patrons
you can become a patron of new rockstars
at patreon.comrockstars you can also get
audio versions of the show by
subscribing to our new rockstars big
question
podcast feed wherever you get your
podcasts and of course you can send us
your questions on twitter
just use the hashtag bigquestion we're
more likely to see it on discord though
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea bots follow zack
huddleston
z huddleston and you can follow new
rockstars on social subscribe here on
youtube to get too much information on
all the stuff you care about
thank you for joining us we'll see you
next week bye
[Music]
you